are you a good girl are you a bad girl
i'm a bad girl
and i'm nice
and that's why people mistake it you
know oh she's such a good girl
but in reality i'm a bad girl
all right corrine
korean oh where'd you go where are you
from originally so corinne my name
it's from
no where are you from oh me i'm from
oregon
oregon yeah i grew up
galley oregon the northern
and i lived in deschutes river woods
which is
a little like cabin type area there's a
lot of pine noodles
tell me about your family growing up you
had mom and dad
i have my mom my dad who were together
for
most of only my childhood
i had my grandmother who
it was her house we stayed in her house
and
i had my uncle who lived in the back of
my grandma's house how would you
describe your childhood
it's a little wild
because i had
chickens and i had um
a whole you know coop
in my grandma's home but
also my grandma had a dog and she had a
parrot
so it was a little crazy and
then again it was a lot of
fun a lot of fun because i just got to
run around with barbed wire all the time
but no i mean how are you treated
nothing nothing crazy going on
nope i was i'm the oldest girl
and i've always been
somewhat of a brat so
growing up i always had
not always i just had a lot
that i could work with and i'm also very
outgoing i like the outdoors
so i would make tree houses and i would
go to
downtown and
i actually
really like my childhood looking back on
it
i had pretty good childhood i i snuck
around smoking cigarettes and
what'd you do after high school
after high school i went to
you mean like after 12
after you graduate high school
which is 12th grade i guess
i just worked i did normal things
i didn't really have any
any path that i wanted to go down
and i could have done anything that i
wanted
i lived in a house that had a couple
acres so
i wrote quads and i just
did what every other teenager was doing
in 12th grade
is somehow you ended up
on the track here in los angeles
i didn't think that i would be out here
but i was born out here
so it brings home to me and
being away from my home
where i've been comfortable and babied i
just
feel a little nervous but i like the
nerve
i think it changes me every time
every time i come out here every time
every day that i think oh i'm in an
entirely different state
i'm like amazed i'm not you know scared
or
what i mean to be
excited
how did you get introduced to sex work
my friend janelle
my friend danielle is so sexy and she
is a cam model
and she used to
just tell me about all these you know
different toys that she had that people
would order for her
and i said well i want some toys like
that and she said well
all you got to do is be a camp model
like it can't be that easy so i went
online
and i did cam modeling for a good
month
started making money
i never did buy myself a toy but i did
start making money and i saw the
difference and then
from the camming it came to oh i don't
have a computer
oh okay well i like dressing up so i'm
gonna dress up and i'm gonna go
nowhere you know so i would dress up and
i would sit there and i would just take
pictures and then
my pictures they started
getting shown on facebook more and more
and more
so i was like you know what maybe i
should just start this dirty little
facebook page
so i got away with it for a little while
and then i decided oh well this is
actual money
and
a blade i
the term kind of strikes for me
but that's what it is and that's what
when i walk on the blade it's all green
lights and i don't know what that means
but it happens every time
so you're working uh
south central l.a
you have a do you have a pimp
south central l.a
trying to cover korra
right trying to stay comfortable
trying to be a woman
but still a sexy lady
i'm just out here you know and i'm
taking off my panties because they're
floral print and i just can't have it
and i'm walking around in
[Music]
heels that i think are attracting
sex appeal
because i know that that's cash
the best way that there is
they're enticed through
you know
adios mio look at that
oh my goodness
and that's what i love to present myself
on to goodness
i can dress all types of dirty but in
the end i'm still
cleaned up
with the fact that
i look good or i feel good
are you a good girl are you a bad girl
i'm a bad girl
and i'm nice
and that's why people mistake it you
know oh she's such a good girl
because she has a high pitched voice
because she
knows
because she doesn't
cuss or slur
but in reality i'm a bad girl
and i do things
on a lot of different whims
trying to strike a new personality or
strike a personality that i've seen or
wanted
i change it up and i
like to be a bad girl because
discipline for me
is always a learning experience and
i think to be
accusated
wrongfully accused
acute
wrongfully
would be
punishable
and so i let people do it
and i take punishment for them
because i'm numb in my whole body
with goodness you know
from being a bad girl
are drugs a part of your life
i think that
with dancing with motion
drugs are a big appeal
and i always also used to think that
in order to stay skinny i had to do
drugs
but i don't think that more and more
as i graduate through
different outfits as i graduate through
different
outcomes
good sex bad sex being a bad girl or
getting caught
being a good girl and not knowing how
i'm still bad
all those things i just
reassure myself every single day of
something
of those things
so every day i'm like you know what i'm
a bad girl
i'm a brat because today i didn't
execute the fact that i'm not wearing a
bra
you know and
i'm a bad girl because i
portray this
that
me not wearing a bra is
my own style
when that's how it is in reality
i'm a bad girl because i instantly
called to whether i'm wild or tame
are you the black sheep of your family
not the black sheep of my family but i
am the most
outspoken and
definitely the first one that
was to dye my hair or
wear you know the color orange
and you work on your own or do you have
a
somebody handling your
managing your business
i had my friend janelle like i said she
and any cam model that i was really
friends with they paid
a lot of money to look and feel the way
that they do
so
i was going from looking great and not
feeling great
to feeling great and looking great
and all i could think was wow like i'm
i'm a bad girl but all my girlfriends
are
you know doing these things too
so
maybe it's all on
what the actual
congregation is
you know and the congregation is sexy
do you enjoy your
work a lot of the time i enjoy my work
i enjoy walking i enjoy meeting people i
enjoy
wearing short dresses and like i
use the word skanky
i enjoy using that word
are you skanky skanky
i
could take up porn i could take up
dancing
and i just know that
they're not making these clothes
for us to ponder at you know they're
making these clothes for us to wear for
us to
curb into our own bodies
for us to look good
every time i look good i'm like
all right i'm accomplishing not only one
thing but
the goal of the close
was it was there anything that you were
just born this way or was there any
something in your childhood that kind of
led you down this path you think
probably a little bit of both
i've always been the oldest but at the
same time there's nothing that could
lead you down a path of just
dressing kind of
outspoken
and it used to be different
so i would wear all black
with you know red and
that was sexy to me
and then it just started changing a
little and i got heels and i
shaved my legs all the way up to the
thigh
and decided that
sexy is a whole different
types of things
how old are you
i'm 27.
do you have kids
i have no kids
i always wanted children
and i just
adopted kids through spirit
and that's what i did as i
went through my whole life you know just
being so conceited about
whether i'm looking good or feeling good
i started
clinging on to certain things and
certain people and i would call them my
children
i could give you a couple examples if
you want
sure
tell me
one of the things that i did
was hurting
hurting was
made up or given
as a item or
a
style
of motion
and he was said to you know
not only
result in
pleasure
but to look good as well
i was like okay how's that gonna work
you know and it's the whole like
you know
thrusting
is a good example
well hurting he went like
up and down
i said you can't go wrong with going up
and down
so i would sit there all day long
and i would just
keep to myself
or you know i would go like back and
forth
and that to me was
keeping a certain style
and it
cured my mind a lot of the time
made me feel better in certain
situations and
hurting i don't know how that name got
to be about but i didn't make it
it was already made like that and
hurting is a person or a talent hurting
is a
ideal
constructed
from
[Music]
a gather
of good or bad things
so hurting is from pine pine is from
pain
you know pain is
extra mended through whatever the case
may be
how does this kind of work affect you
emotionally anyway hurting was one of my
children that's what i was getting at oh
okay
how does doing this kind of work affect
you emotionally
emotionally it's a little
chalky
there's a lot of situations that i get
into where i just
i'm feeling so
sponuous or
sentimental
and i think back or i get put in my
place where you're not allowed to feel
that way about this situation
like wow darn
it's a throbbing moment
and it happens like
occasionally not all the time not often
but occasionally
where i'm
questioned
you know what is it that you're feeling
right now do you deserve it
can you name it on a spectrum that
is appeasing
can you make other people want what you
have right now
and if you can then it's
a term
you know
and there's a name for it it's sex
appeal
it's deriving from
something that you
want someone else to yearn for
are you lonely
lonely
but i forget the word
easily and often i forget the word
and i replace it with
independent
or
careful
i do things on my own by my own
but on terms it's just lonely
such a lonely day
and it's mine
what do you think most
people outside this
this kind of work don't understand about
girls that that do this
some things i hate the word in general
that's
it's just
the word
torn down and brought back up and hidden
and
you know
regained
i always found another word to place
instead of that word but when it came
down to it when i was being questioned
about it or when i was saying it an
example
i would use that word prostitute and
not one weight
was lifted off of me
whether i said it or whether i said
presenteth
which is what i always had to cloud my
mind saying oh well that's not it that's
not what i'm doing
i present it that's
the same exact thing
what term do you prefer
what do you use i prefer presented
more so
well now
it's like you get to the adults where
the adults are like no this is what it
is
you know women are out there like this
is my whole life and you're sitting here
like it's just a job
i'm sitting here
as myself
saying it's a preference
nor is it a job nor is it a title of
your own humanity but it's just a
preference of living
sexual versus non-sexual
giving or
you know
bling
i guess the word is
glamorous
sexy
did you have dreams of doing something
different with your life when you were
young
no
no
i saw myself very
very rule
this is the way i am now
that's how i saw myself yeah
and
any ending that i would have now is
something that i have seen before
or something that i know i can see
just because of the sexual trials that
i've gone through in my
prostitution of
this angle
in my presented of
my whole life compared to things that
i've done or things that i would do
the way that i dress
things that i would do or things that
i've done
have you been in love before
what was that have you been in love
before
yeah
sorry excuse me
yeah
in love
now so
that i'm going through the trials of
i would prostitute my wife
i've heard that said
to the trials of no i'm just prostitute
and i just don't have any love
all i have is sex and i don't know what
to do with it
i can see
how someone could be that way about
their life but i couldn't be that way
about mine
i believe in
marriage i believe in
two people being exquisite of
an act stronger than
any pleasure
an act of creation
of
anything else
so i've been in love and i like being in
love
and i like from promoting
all the you know
all the good groot
root sorry the root of being in love
tell me about how this kind of work has
affected your
your view of men
are a lot of your clients married
yep and they have a name they're called
sowelu
beggars i call them beggars
not for any term or reason just
beggars of showing
you know beggars of proof
how is this beggar's up sexy
how has this kind of work affected your
changed your view of men
it's absent
it taps in pretty hard a lot of the time
because
i don't want to ex
i don't want to exotic to somebody who's
married
and i have a firm rule against it
but other people you know they show up
they try to crack codes they try to
give exceptions and i'm just like you
don't understand though like the respect
that i have is
no longer sex appeal or
work it's
adoration
is honor toward another couple
things that prevent me from
working well
when people are in love in front of me
or you know when i'm shown in love
what advice would you give to a young
girl who's thinking about doing this
kind of work
young girl do you recommend it
yes young girl
if you're thinking about doing this line
of work
i would just say raise a bar
always raise a bar in something that
you're thinking of
putting a whole line of work into
because
i know the term and i've seen the women
and they should all be fancy finagled
touched but not
abrupted
to a halt or a
motion
you know i saw this
female who was in her underwear
and a long shirt
and she ran around and she had sex with
whoever and
you know what i mean and that was just
a type of
work or a type of stoop that she had
but in my eyes in my
inner mind i still thought of her as
prostitute
i'm sorry
do you think prostitution should be
legalized
i think it should be legalized
i think that's good a job as any
you
get a certain way of dress
you behave a certain behavior
it feels good feeling good so there's no
point to end something that could just
accumulate more
grid of union
therapist in some ways
yeah
do you believe in monogamy
you think
humans were meant to be faithful to one
partner forever
i do believe in monogamy
i wouldn't choose it personally
but i've seen it and i've
been around you know the
bias of it
it's just not something that i
i would advertise or practice
yeah
or even pay attention to you know i
wouldn't send it a vote i wouldn't raise
my hand for it
what examples of a uh
loving relationship where they're in
your in your life growing up
good example of love in my
life growing up would be
my love that i had with my brother
because
it was a connection of closeness where
there was a respect demanded and the
respect was met and because of those two
things
there was production being made at all
times
and
my brother walked in on me one time and
i had
you know
things going on for me it's not that he
saw
a [ __ ] or that he thought oh a met like
immediately this skank is giving head to
her boyfriend and i walk in
but he thought
you
you skank he said
you skank
and i just thought about it for the
longest time like this is my boyfriend
in my room
that you've walked in on and you're
calling me a skank
and i just i couldn't
i couldn't explain to him how
the fahrenheit was not equal
you know like
it was
a situation that did not call for a
skank called
to be
but yeah that's what he said and so i
just laughed about it for the longest
time
you don't understand skank if you think
how does doing this kind of work affect
your self-worth
or your self-esteem
does it make you feel
does it make you feel good about
yourself or does it
do the opposite
it's a steep
and shallow hill
and there's good and there's bad
there's always going to be women and
especially women
who are going to sit there and say you
know oh well i do this better or
well i'm going to show you how to be a
prostitute and you have to take those
into
hard consideration of the fact that like
everyone's tip of t is different
but there's no
wrong answer to something that is being
relinquished as pleasure
that's why there are so many different
you know spartacle spectacles
of a certain things because like that
one topic that the
the humankind
gathered that one topic
ended up being one of the best topics
one that everyone could understand one
that everyone was like pleasure okay
let's see what we're doing here
you know they
really did good on that
the word
the temperament the uh
the motion
do you have any regrets in your life
i always used to think no
i have no regrets in your life
and of course i've gotten older and i've
had regrets in my life definitely
most of them are
just situations that i had behavior on
myself
some of the situations are things that
are just
outcomed
to be that way when i don't want them to
be that way
but
there's no really hard
regrets that i have
other than you know my marriage
or like being in love
you know you either regret being in love
or you love being in love because either
way you're stuck with
something that you didn't have before
you're changed
you were married once
i was almost married almost married
like on proposal on
yeah
fiance
would you describe yourself as happy
at this point in your life
i would describe myself as pushing
not typically happy or unhappy but
pushing
for something or
for a feeling or a word
and
some days i get that satisfaction and
that's you know the perks of being
prostituted is that oh okay i feel good
right now
i'm feeling good right now
and the perks are you know
money or
open
you know
open
action
against whoever or to whoever
and the downfalls are the same exact
thing
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
not to
residuate on things not to
hold sore lip
i'm sorry
not to pout
it's important
being some
flu of
caring
and not caring in a way like
caring to one another but caring in a
way of like
well i have this piece of trash and this
piece of trash is going to you know
affect whatever area that i shed down
now i have the short dress
you